sont des voitures qui ne cessent
d'arriver des gens qui ont patienté
souvent plusieurs heures pour pouvoir
franchir ce poste frontière et bien
souvent on voit aussi arriver des gens à
pied qui ont dû marcher pendant des
heures et qui sont ici pris en charge
par les autorités polonaises on leur met
notamment des couvertures pour se
réchauffer alors ce n'est pas encore un
exode massif un afflux massif
les autorités s'attendent tout de même
dans les heures qui viennent à des
arrivées beaucoup plus nombreuse neuf
centres d'hébergement et d'accueil ont
été mises en place côté polonais de la
frontière les hôpitaux sont également en
alerte pour accueillir jusqu'à 1000
réfugiés qui seraient blessés les
autorités américaines avec les soldats
américains qui possède plusieurs bases
ici sont également prêts à assister ces
réfugiés et d'autres pays notamment
l'allemagne ont déjà proposé leur
assistance